[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another beautiful day here in
Utah the Nichols family is getting
packed and getting ready to leave on a
plane to Alaska so yeah we got a lot to
do today well we're sitting here packing
up and we have a little bit of a big
moment here
Jacob started saying mama yeah this is a
big get for Becca because Tommy's first
word was fish and his second word was
data and then several months later mama
Oh getting repackage or all right guys
let's go to the post office we gotta
send some of these gifts off to people
so we don't have to lug them around
forever all right guys well the post
office visit didn't go well
[Applause]
the boys went absolutely bonkers and
started a full brawl wrestling match
that nearly injured a disabled what did
I do
well guys we're finally packed and it
has now become obvious exactly how much
fishing gear and souvenirs we've
purchased cuz we went from essentially
three checked bags to six its blued
quickly honest well we're all packed up
and we've got a few hours before we need
a head to the airport and so Becca
wanted to go back up to the cabin one
more time
do you have a good time babes
yeah well guys it's been fun we had a
good time but we gotta get back to Salt
Lake load up the baggage into the car
and head out to the airport
Tommy how hungry are you
[Music]
German things
kind of nostalgic every time I come to
this Airport because I remember working
on the construction of this Airport
terminal
[Music]
okay guys we made it we're in the car
roll over here local time is 11:55 p.m.
and it's the Sun is just barely set
welcome to Alaska in July are you glad
to see uncle Curtis it's is he your
favorite it's great to be back in Alaska
it's great to see the family the kids
are so stoked to play their uncles aunts
and cousins but it's past midnight here
and we've got to get to bed so I will
pick this up tomorrow morning it's
absolutely gorgeous the Sun has been up
for many hours you might go over to
Grandma's grandma's place what everyone
else takes their time we're going on
break misadventure so we got a good
chunk of the family here in the car and
we're gonna go out to breakfast in the
family oh yeah you guys we go to
gwennie's all right let's go for
breakfast all right guys we're here at
gwennie's this is kind of one of those
old the last kind of restaurants
if you want burgers pancakes that sort
of things I been around for amber then a
couple years since I've eaten here
though hey Tom
see what that is yeah that's a king
salmon that's whale baleen that goes
inside the mouth of whales the 1964
earthquake my parents were here when
this happened sourdough pancakes
reindeer sausage got myself some free
bumper stickers we pick up a bonus
nickel Haitian selfie hi
relax alright guys we're here who's
ready to get muskie look at this swarm
of nickels and Rapa Lee's here we are
gonna descend upon this place go ahead
and kill a musk ox and bring back the
shoulder blade because I'm gonna whoop
you with it Tommy
behave yourself but the musk ox will eat
you muskox are wiser than we are just
because it came out of yet doesn't mean
it's good
during rut though nobody in the farm oh
we will trim the tips of their horns
[Music]
light feel free to pass it around and
feel how light it is
who's Nathan let's go
well let's go get some ice cream shall
we guys Wow
yeah there we go
[Music]
it's kind of like a me like that is that
good at the large that's right it
reflects me you grab that take it
outside buddy so this is one of the
little Miller ice cream shops here in
the valley now the big ones up a little
further north but here in Wasilla and
you want to get some soft-serve ice
cream not a bad place to do it
[Music]
the boys are two because there was some
epic meltdowns on the way home yeah I'm
tired I'm tired but you know we're gonna
just take it easy eat with the family
have some hamburgers and just enjoy a
beautiful day I love how my sons can
play in this big huge field and not
worry about snakes or ticks or spiders
you know as long as there's not a moose
or a bear back there we're good to go
[Music]
[Applause]
well guys it's 9:30 at night
the kids are in bed it's late and I'm
going to sleep
it's a beautiful Sunday morning and
we're getting all dappered up and ready
to go to church I'm looking forward to
this we're gonna go with the whole
family and it's just just gonna be great
to see everybody and spend some time on
a low-key Sunday I'm staying here with
my sister and she's introduced me to
chocolate marshmallow mateys
holy mackerel never has getting diabetes
been so fun looks like cocoa puffs and
marshmallows to me
[Music]
I'm gonna turn off the camera because
apparently v-log in the worship service
is frowned upon all right lunch my
sister is a famous see I'm up to nine or
ten sweet I'll put some links in the
description so you can check them out
[Music]
well he got myself a very unhealthy
lunch here I'm gonna hang out let the
kids play a little bit then we're gonna
go visit my grandparents and introduce
them to Jacob because they haven't had a
chance to meet him yet all right great
grandpa Nichols now they have never met
little Jacob all right guys come on guys
ready this is great grandpa is that a
toy box I remember this thing I remember
this I used to play with this when I was
a little little kid are you playing with
yeah
see thank you oh say goodbye guys
[Music]
[Music]
this trip has been a real big milestone
for Jacob he's grown a ton since we've
left he really learned to roll over on
his own on this trip and he was in that
bouncer rolled himself out rolled under
the TV and then has rolled all the way
over here oh here we go
so Tommy and Nathan are hanging out with
the cousins here and the field and
they're playing tiger attack the boys
are just excited to be able to run
through tall grass and not get covered
in ticks well it's a beautiful day and
the kids are already up and playing with
cousins and today's a little bit of a
question mark day we've got a big family
picnic celebrating my parents 50th
wedding anniversary but the rest of the
day is kind of up in the air Becca needs
to do some work because she's got a
major conference coming up at the end of
this week and so it's a little bit of a
low-key thing we can't run out of town
and go do any big fishing adventures or
anything but let me see if we can't find
something really fun to do
me and my brother-in-law Curtis here
we're gonna see if we can't defeat the
flood challenge so I'm here at a
restaurant called fanatics and it's a
Vietnamese food and cuisine and it
specializes in making [ __ ] that spelled
pho but this place has the fudge
hallenge which is like this massive bit
of fun that if you can eat it all
it's you win 500 bucks otherwise it cost
you like 60 and it's like two pounds of
noodles two pounds of meat and
sixty-four ounces of broth that's what
their website said so me and Curtis
we're gonna go in here and see if see if
we can handle the fudge challenge you
even have to sign a waiver so I gotta
put the camera down and I got to read
the waiver here I'm at least 18 resident
of the United States a good physical and
mental health no guys Curtis not just
for his charming personality here but he
is the 3-time Buffalo Wild Wings spicy
wings challenge winner yes so I'm
bringing in the heat and our designated
driver is Ethan here like my nephew
who's going to make sure I get home all
right so we've got the Wall of shame
with everybody who tried and failed
infamy and defeat all right he's doing
like a warm-up exercise over there I
don't know I'm obviously this big this
outlet I even ate breakfast before
that's not hollow you know that's
here you go crab guys you should have
like a back brace if you carry than that
oh crap I'm already sweating guys every
journey begins with a single footstep
hmm that's good good yeah that's good
[ __ ]
oh yeah this is how you really do it you
know it's actually really tasty fun
which is a good thing you know often
when you think about eating challenges
you don't think of it being very good
this is really good fun so in case you
don't know what the foie is it's a
Vietnamese dish and it usually has lots
of different types of meat usually pork
or beef and you have bean sprouts you
have Thai basil green onions limes
there's this really yummy sweet brown
sauce you put in there that's good or if
you like a little spicy and put a little
sriracha sauce in there sometimes they
put jalapenos in there what I like is
how it slides down the gullet really
well liquid helps really it's just
amazing how you feel a bit pretty good
I'm intimidated
[Laughter]
I feel like I've eaten so much but
hasn't touched it look at this guy's
there is just noodles noodles
I don't worry about winning at this but
I was worried about not shaving myself
some pack the food more fun just
watching the guys I'm really full up
starting to fight that rule
regurgitation reflex like swallowing
things twice his wife made it very clear
she wouldn't respect him anymore if he
failed smiling on the outside but I'm
crying on the inside
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna need a lot of doggie bags
[Music]
yeah the toughest challenge in Alaska I
believe that promise teased and all the
leftover fun you can handle tell so many
honorable brave young men and women
before us so guys if you were ever in
Anchorage and you want to try the
ultimate bug challenge please come to
fanatics and look for me and curtis's
photo up here on the wall the wall of
shame we're proud of our shame I see
this before and after before so here's
our our doggie bags here Ortega we
brought leftovers all right guys we're
here at Cabela's we're gonna go pick up
a few things get my fishing license I'm
gonna grab a little basket so that I
won't buy too much fishing gear you know
they got dip nets here it's for scooping
salmon out of the river 60 not 16 that
right there is a big swim bait so check
it out these are shrimp pellets they use
these like shrimp traps and for chumming
stuff how awesome would these be for
catfish I love this
if you sell sudden impact fiber punch
bait in Alaska there are no catfish in
the state of Alaska you must be using
that for strip traps or crab traps all
right I've got some basic supplies got
my license so do some fishing today well
here we are at Jewell Lake and we're
gonna bust out the ultralight rods and
see if we can catch a few trout I can
see some trout right there you can see
them right there I can see him
[Music]
yeah yeah let's raise them up yeah there
it goes
hey Nathan did you want a fish let's
been fun we've been about 45 minutes
here this is the lake just put a little
nymph and a split shot on a spinning rod
and caught caught four fish so you know
a little stalkers nothing nothing big
but kind of fun alright guys let's go to
that family picnic Shelley so you go get
mommy and Jacob - this is Campbell Creek
and we're at Campbell Creek Park the
whole family picnic but this Creek gets
salmon in it you can get silver salmon
and we used to fish for Silver's in here
but it's a little early for Silver's
[Music]
what your hot dog yeah which one cost 20
bucks yeah they are so my parents are
celebrating their 50th anniversary here
this year so that's kind of what this
whole shindig is for so hey go mom go
dad all right so the rain kicked up on
us got a nice little drizzle here so
we're gonna move this party indoors all
right guys we're gonna go up to our
cabin and see if we can't catch some
fish we're gonna drive two hours north
stay the night at the cabin and then go
fishing early tomorrow morning and come
back tomorrow so a little bit of a long
night
let's do it we are at Taco Bell and we
just ordered what like 40 something
tacos
24 tacos oh you know you're buying a lot
of times when you need to sign for it
the mild the fire in Diablos that one
okay who's the burrito person
watch the big grouse right there way
past my boys bedtime so we got to get
them Tibet we're a little early for the
silver salmon run so it's a big fat
question mark whether there's gonna be
any salmon in the river tomorrow morning
thanks for watching and we hope you
enjoyed this video check out this sneak
peek of the next installment of the 2018
World Tour if you like this video log
series don't forget to click the
playlist link into the video description
below thanks for watching if you want to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning